okay fantastic episode 169 we are live
today
with the legendary rick sanchez from
miami who has a podcast called rick
sanchez news on apple podcast he runs a
company called agua another one that he
was a cmo part of the debate you're
upset am i hearing the sound now is that
the intro
[Laughter]
they messing with you are you is this a
prank the the crew on the bank tell us
what you're doing
can i go or no you just just got to give
me the green apple guys we're good okay
sounds good are we live right now is
this happening no listen they're having
one too many drinks in the pack yeah
which is totally fine
you've never heard that anyways rick
sanchez is on if you're if you don't
know him you you didn't watch tv i don't
know miami he's like he can't walk in
the streets of miami legend i grew up
watching this but here's the kicker
though the kicker that we just learned
is he goes from being a guy with cnn
doing all the stuff that he's doing the
controversy with uh you know cooper or
or jon stewart which john said that's
not a big deal what he said
to being a cmo of a company that just
went public
kano uh health
uh as a co-founder that just went public
at 4.4 billion dollar valuation which is
kind of cool bought himself a nice place
won't tell you where it is but uh in a
very good place rick great to have you
on the podcast it's great to be here pat
yeah you know uh
i'm a fan uh ever since you hit you know
people say this to me all the time i did
not grow up watching you by the way
did you get that you know i'm right
there with you but but i will say this
that you've had a very alluring effect
on people ever since you've hit the
airwaves man so you're doing a good job
i don't know what it is
but you draw people in dude so that's a
very good thing apparently what vinnie
and adam tried to say today is what what
it is is most people can't guess my age
and apparently adam's friends think i'm
in my mid 50s late 50s shocked that he's
in his early 40s shocked that he's in
his like and but it's not that you
seem old it's just
you carry yourself you always said it
don't worry
being this big this big of a personality
this big just as a person he can he
could not be nothing else but being this
guy like pat can't be a freaking uber
driver because how hey you wouldn't fit
in the car but number two this
what else would you do i'd be the i'd be
the leader in five stars though i'd have
100
by the way i can see you as a funny as
hell uber driver if we did like a
mock-up we tested them we get them to be
an uber driver before then we record it
that's one hundred percent hilarious
fyi uh
we're driver in hialeah
hey so so vinnie's got a new thing
coming out guys i just want to preface
this please do not be offended when it
comes out and if you are totally okay
with that yeah so vinnie's got a new
skit coming out
and i'm i'm on the road well i don't
know where i'm at i'm on the road i get
a text message sent to me with a picture
saying
vinnie's no joke vinnie's walking around
the office in a g string
[Laughter]
i don't know what that is i have no clue
what this is it's the story of who what
the guy what okay guys i i don't give
away too much but a guy that works in
the office right and he was in a freak
paper shredding accident but he's one of
those guys that just loves his job they
brought him back and he just said listen
i don't want to sue just let me keep my
job and just don't make me feel weird at
work and he's in the office and he
doesn't have any arms so you can imagine
what he uses anyway so whoa
yeah it's gonna that's gonna be
interesting to see how the audience
responds to it anyways we've got a lot
of things to cover today rick i want to
get some of your thoughts and feedbacks
obviously you being from you being cuban
uh uh i want to know who the most
influential hispanic is that's dictating
the direction politics are going in the
fastest growing community in america
which is hispanics it's the most
important vote today that both sides are
trying to win over yeah and they're
paying very very close attention to it
uh some events that took place in
highland park we have to talk about the
tragic event that took place in highland
park this week
and uh
some of the stuff just makes no sense by
the way rogan's comments on trump that
he said he would never have him on the
podcast never reached that he said no
i'm gonna hear some commentary yeah we
had a friendly wager on that yeah we
were tempted to yeah we and you but you
said no though you said no you chickened
out i thought you were giving me good
odds why would i take it
out he said he would never do it why
would i give you good we'll get into it
so anyways rep uh uh adam kinzinger
releases explicit
uh laced audio of numerous calls to dc
office threatening violence frustrated
democrats express alarm over biden's
powerlessness
uh tens of millions of people on
lockdown in china governor newsom enjoys
montana vacation despite lgbtq state
travel ban
tick tock admits china-based employees
can access over u.s user data this is a
weird story this next one largest
teachers union florida is 9 000 teachers
short
for the upcoming school year
and then we got a couple other stories
that we'll get into so let's start with
what you first mentioned because i think
that's really fascinating um
latinos right in the united states
because this goes to what you mentioned
a little while ago with cano health as
well
um it's a frustrating time to be a
latino in the united states we're a
community that is somewhat leaderless
and let me just give you some basic
numbers
uh if you're at home taking notes this
is why i am now founding
agua media with uh the proceeds from
kenno health essentially i don't want to
get a yacht and just go around the
caribbean i want to do something that's
important for this country important as
a latino american who lives in the
united states and it's this look
we are the third fastest growing gdp in
the world only behind
china and india and ahead of the united
states itself in case you missed that
let me say it again
latinos in america if they were a
country would be the third fastest
growing gdp nationwide in the world
ahead of the united states and only
behind china and india and catching up
in terms of total gdp latinos in the
united states are the seventh largest
gdp if they were a nation in the world
and i know because i know some of the
folks at stanford who are preparing the
next report that we're about to move up
on that list i mean and when you look at
latinos in the united states just just
general numbers common age of a latino
in america 11.
wow common age of a white anglo-saxon in
america 58.
where do you think the future lies i
mean you can look it from a consumer
standpoint i mean the economics are
literally undeniable at this point and
yes you say 11 11.
wow common age according to the pew
study of a latino in america and by the
way common age not average age common
age is more of a
it's a mode so the mode is the
combination of both the average and
something else so in other words if you
were to look at all the latinos what
would be the one that would find that
11. which is which is without getting
too much into the to the metrics you're
basically saying white people are
getting older and they're dying soon and
latinos are getting younger and hotter
yeah that's why they hired him here
that's exactly why
i thought it was more like latinos have
more sex than white i was just gonna say
they're better at making babies
hopefully it's not the 11 year olds well
yeah i think the number keep it clean we
could look it up but i think the number
on that is that the
you know if you want to say white people
or whatever we want to call them have uh
index where they're not yet doing one cr
recreating themselves they're less than
one person in terms of breeding
to use a word that maybe we shouldn't
but latinos on the other hand are close
to duplicating themselves almost to the
point of two so yes the latinos have a
tendency maybe it's the catholics so
please continue these stats are very
interesting so common age 11 latino
common age of white is 58 here's another
one that i think is fascinating uh
latinos under the age of 41. 95 percent
of them speak english
80 41 under 41 95 speak english not down
in little havana bro no no um
80 are u.s citizens
so the reason i'm saying these things is
because it flies in the face of what we
see on television whether you're
watching cnn or rachel maddow or sean
hannity
it's all the same i mean it it's either
looking at latinos and patting them on
the head and saying good latino good
latino very good oh we love you or or on
fox news where they tend to be a little
more aggressive in their coverage of
latino because everything is about the
border and we got to shut it down
because these people are coming over
here either way the representation
doesn't exist less than two percent of
the people who appear on cable news or
national news are latino whereas if you
look at other cohorts it's much much
higher so let's just do the numbers
latinos are 20 of the population in the
united states and in the next 10 years
we might be essentially one-fourth of
the population
and yet hollywood casts us 37 percent of
the time as criminals
and 27 of the times as workers losers
kind of people who are not successful
so they in in a sense are putting into
the mind of the american populace who we
are and then the cable news channels run
within and do all this other stuff and
what you have in the end is a lack of
representation you know a lack of being
able to understand what this cohort is
that lives in america which by the way
was here before the pilgrims
the first thanksgiving was celebrated by
spanish people in saint augustine
not at plymouth rock in massachusetts
and it was 70 years before and there was
actually a second one in santa fe new
mexico so the history of latinos the
numbers of latinos the data that i'm
sharing with you speaks to the fact that
this is a cohort which is in many ways
driving the us economy and as you set
vince is going to be driving the next
the u.s economy for a long time so
for me it's frustrating as a latino uh
seeing this having my experiences in big
media as you mentioned i've worked at
fox i've worked at all these places and
i've never seen
them being able to grasp this now when i
left cnn and i had to do something and i
used my brand which i think
is an interesting story as you said
patrick where i was able to take the
rick sanchez brand people know who i am
i'm a pretty good writer i know a little
bit about marketing and i know a little
bit about messaging because i've been
doing it all my life i've interviewed
four presidents mikhail gorbachev fidel
castro i've got three peabodies i've got
five emmys i know a little bit about
this business so i use that to help
create a new healthcare company that we
started that's just called cano health
and kennel health has done very well and
we started and three and a half to four
years later we went public and it's a
4.4 billion dollar company and when that
happened my wife and i slapped each
other fives and she said let's get a
yacht and take off and i said no the one
thing i've always wanted to do is create
a space
an outlet for latinos in the united
states and that is why now i'm creating
agua media
a lot like what you guys are doing here
patrick which is that's what i said it's
based out of what it's based out of
miami based out of south florida okay so
by the way i think timing of it is a
great uh with what you're doing with
aqua
uh
uh
who who would be right now so right now
when i when i talk to hispanics and i
ask them who their uh uh who they go to
to get their political
advice or political you know
philosophies the jesus of political
philosophies for the hispanic community
is jorge ramos i mean he's the guy right
what made yes and no well i mean so who
would be the other side well
the other the only reason i'm going to
push back on you on that is because
jorge ramos barely speaks english so if
if you go by the statistics that i just
shared with you 95 under 41 95 under 41
speak english
of those
they i think it's 75 primarily speak
english and something like 45 don't even
know how to speak spanish so those
people barely even know who the hell
jorge ramos is but the jorge jorge ramos
influenced their parents and their
parents influenced the kids so well
influences going through
what he's done to the parents so why do
you think parents and and and
i think it's important for the audience
to know this why don't we go to this
verse and i'll go to the parent's side
with jorge ramos um
what is the difference between a
cuban political philosophy versus a
mexican
versus a puerto rican
and versus some others honduras you know
you got
other hispanic because it's not when
you're saying hispanic
they don't all lean the same way
political i don't know and you could say
by the way and you know uh
you can say the same thing about
everyone but in to answer your question
more directly
the latinos who have come to the united
states recently and fled an oppressive
political regime as opposed to latinos
who have come to the united states over
the years
uh fleeing from what are
oppressive economic conditions are two
different types of individuals so the
cuban comes here like the vietnamese
comes here like uh
the venezuelans uh come here which is
what we see in miami for the most part
and they're angry they're angry that
they got a guy like castro or a guy like
chavez who's taken over their country
who's a freaking totalitarian
communist sob and
so as soon as they get here they they
hitch their wagon to the republican
party because the republican party is
the one that's always yelling you know
communist communist
and they come here yelling communist
communist so it's a perfect match
um
that sense obviously as you said is more
adherent in the older communities among
the cubans and the venezuelans and the
ones who have recently arrived
so that's the reason for that it's it's
a political feeling it's almost like
i've been put upon i'm in america this
country is anti-communist and the
republican party is anti-communist so
this is why i'm going to go with this
party the um
the honduran americans the
mexican-americans the others out west
for example and even to a certain extent
puerto ricans who live in new york are
the new york weekends
they see it a little bit differently
they've been here for a longer period of
time and they're more ingrained and
they're less political and they're more
economic so they see the world a little
bit differently they tend to hang with
the democratic party or the more
progressive way of looking at things and
those are the reasons for those two uh
ideological or political ideologies but
when you really break them down
everything else they're pretty much the
same yeah they go to the same church
they they're both they're both uh
hard-working uh they're both uh into
family they're very traditional all the
things about very much so yeah very much
the values of the hispanic community
across the board i mean the insurance
company we run were 42 hispanic and it's
not from one you know area it's mexican
salvadorian guatemalan ecuador you know
honduras it doesn't matter we have them
all
in a company in hardworking strong
family
rowdy
fun to be around
very uh attractive energy the way they
are
uh you know they they enjoy having fun
they're good people to be around but you
sit there and you say so the party you
said about jorge ramos okay so he said
jorge ramos is the ones that are older
the population that follows jorge
ramos's influence okay so if jorge ramos
is older
and those who speak english don't follow
jorge ramos or fall on aoc so both ways
they're getting the same messaging from
the same philosophies but they escaped a
lot of the stuff that those two are
selling them yeah an aoc i don't see her
as latina i mean
she came out with something last week
saying that anybody who doesn't use the
term latinx should not be considered
what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
i mean are you crazy i mean latin first
of all
why do we have to change our name latina
is a beautiful word by the way of course
latina is a beautiful word and that
latina can't call herself latina anymore
she has to call herself latinx the
language of my parents the languages my
grandparents the language that comes
from spain we have to change and all of
a sudden call it latinx because aoc
decided that we should be what the f
what
what is latinx by the way no idea i
don't even like some think tank some
liberal think tank somewhere decided
we're gonna ch why don't you change all
the irish people to irish acts you know
it's never going to talk
in there
you know whatever the hell you are i
don't know don't try to figure it out i
mean why do we get the act and the crazy
thing is i'm telling you right now
aoc once you get to that point she's
going to run for president and that type
of person with her hip and texting and
tweeting those are the type of people
that are gonna win the presidency when
it comes around to their time let me
tell you something else i'm telling you
let me tell you something else about
latinx the only people who use the term
latinx are not latinos yeah exactly of
course three percent of latinos don't
even know what the hell it is
the other ones hate it i thought 98 of
latinos don't want to be called uh no
they hate it so that's things this is
this is what patrick is getting at
who the hell out there is creating the
rules for latinos because they're
obviously not latinos well let me ask
you because i think this is going to
mean to go oh no no it was great your
account was great um what i think you're
saying is and what pat's question was is
that latinos are not monolithic no it's
a very diverse group but before you get
too far on being not monolithic who the
hell is
yeah no americans monolithic
but but that's my point is that
um
i think there's a place where i can
bring them together with agua media and
that's why we're doing aguamedia and
that's why i do stories in the middle of
the stories i stop and tell the viewer
let me give you a latino perspective on
this story so whether i'm doing foreign
policy ukraine china or quesaya what i
do is i try to i try to do what
everybody else has always done in this
culture except latinos we've not been
allowed to do it go into the media
mainstream or whatever the hell you want
to call it and tell a story with a
little bit of our perspective a little
bit of our juice a little bit of our dna
because there ain't nobody out there
doing it the last guy who did it was
some dude on cnn named rick sanchez and
they fired him and they've never
replaced him so you don't see anymore
there's not one guy on television in
america who happens to be latino anymore
they don't exist you don't consider her
aldo rivera latino oh god she's still
alive
no actually you know mustaches he's a
good guy he's a good guy but but
to say that he has a natural why do you
think there is not a bigger platform for
latinos i mean they're 30 of america
you're saying are 20 25. why aren't
there numerous latinos on tv that is the
question for the ages and that is why
agua media was born and that's why saul
trujillo and i
have come together to create this entity
because i think if ain't nobody else
gonna do it maybe it's time we do it
ourselves so we want to create something
akin to what you guys are doing here
where we're able to essentially find
spaces in the media where we can tell
all the stories that everybody else is
already hearing but with our dna our
perspective what what what do you think
was
what worked for jorge ramos what made
jorge ramos as famous as he is today as
influential in the hispanic community
latino community as he is today slam
dunk first of all uh let me start with
this great guy
great journalist
adheres to journalistic principles
forthright uh
uh telegenic handsome looks good
uh mexican uh so all of that was there
so from a casting standpoint he's cast
right but here's really the most
important thing
when when when somebody had the
brainstorm of thinking you know it's
funny we've got all these uh
we've got all these oyez living in
america right we've got all these
hispanics living in america
and they don't have a television channel
they don't have a television network so
let's begin something called univision
so the essence the creation the business
idea of to flourish a
concept of a spanish-speaking television
network
was brilliant and once they did that and
they implemented the news and they chose
jorge ramo whether it had been jorge
ramos or anybody else that would have
been successful it was more successful
with jorge because he was cast correctly
so that's it right place right time
patrick and then his messaging how is
his messaging connecting with the odd
with the hispanic audience
because all that i get all that stuff i
get
uh fine but he's
he's more than just looks and a guy that
gets on and talks he's got strong
opinions he's got strong you know
uh beliefs how did that connect with the
hispanic audience the way it has well
um you know it's funny a lot of the
folks that i've hired uh i've taken from
univision because uh
you know terrestrial television for the
most part is kind of you know weakening
shall we say so there's a lot of people
are real smart out there who are
available so i get the conversations
with a lot of these guys and they tell
me what it was like in the beginning
when they first started
but let me give you my opinion
i don't want to be like univision i
don't want to be like telemundo i don't
want to be like jorge ramos though i
love jorge ramos and we're good friends
and i respect the hell out of him
because what they have had to do for
their audience
is bring it down patrick to
victimization
so if you were to do a content analysis
of their newscasts for example or their
content in general what you would find
is that they tend to do the woe with me
a lot
this poor guy was put upon was stopped
by police and beat up and he's the lead
story this lady didn't get her food
stamps etc etc so rather than what i
think is the message that i've been
talking about here latinos are driving
the us economy we are leading in
entrepreneurship you are latino is more
apt to start a business in america right
now than any other cohort latinos are
hiring people at a faster pace than any
other cohort again you're not hearing
that from warrior ramos in univision
you're getting the victimization stories
and that in and of itself plays into the
scene of oh poor guys poor latinos i
don't want this should not be about poor
latinos oh look at them rachel maddow's
patting us on the head it should be
about look at these mother look at these
guys look what they're doing look how
important they are to the us economy and
rather than putting up a fence
and and keeping them out while we send
our jobs to vietnam we should be letting
them in and saying hey we need to start
more plants and creating people here who
work their asses off but i got a
question for you so let me let me push
back on that a little bit okay so the
woe is me oh my gosh like look they're
never they're never looking at us they
don't they they don't do anything but
look how poor we are look how this we
are okay
we are seeing uh msnbc
is replacing rachel maddow with alex
wagner i believe so they're going a
complete different direction with rachel
maddow that announcement came back
yesterday right you're starting to see
msnbc and cnn kind of sit there and say
uh the russia scandal that we kept
talking about kind of backfired on us
guys we got to go a different direction
you kind of seen zucker had to get fired
somebody had to get fired to show that
well the whole guy behind all of this
stuff was zucker and then crew como was
gone and this guy's gone and that guy's
gone so they have to revamp the whole
imaging because they realize that
messaging didn't work for cnn or msnbc
rogan is destroying them tucker is
destroying them and that's just the
truth podcasters are killing them
shapiro's doing laps around them and i
can give you a bunch of these other
statistics you see them you're in the
world right
meaning
that messaging didn't resonate with
their audience my question for you is
why is ramos's messaging of what was me
resonating with the hispanic audience
because they speak spanish and where
else are they going to go there's only
two networks telemundo and univision and
they basically spit the ratings so if if
all you have is a store if you have a
three supermarkets and fifty percent of
the population is latino in your
neighborhood and one of them is
hungarian and the other one is uh gringo
and the third one is latino
is that 50 gonna buy their goods they're
going to buy it at the latino store you
could say they make the same argument
for univision and telemundo they just
happen to be placed in such a place
where that's the only place you can go
to get your stuff
unfortunately for them that population
the population that only wants to get
their information or their content to
spanish is diminishing if not dying off
to a certain extent are they do they do
you know uh is univision would you say
univision and telemundo do they lean
left
hardcore hardcore both of them sure sure
i mean it's not even a question it
almost they almost have to i mean you're
talking i mean what what are you gonna a
guy who came to the united states last
week came here for economic conditions
the the story that you write for him and
prepare for him is usually one more of
as i said earlier more of a woe is me
kind of story and that's where that's
where i don't like the victimization
thing to come in and that doesn't mean
that i want to lean right either because
i don't think that's correct either
because uh unfortunately there are too
many forces on the right including my
buddies over there my buddy tucker at uh
fox news who too often
don't understand the things that i'm
talking about right now vince where
where essentially they're you know
they speak of latinos as if the only
thing they could say about latinos is
that they crossed the border last week
they came here and they're going to rape
your daughter yeah and i'm sorry but
that's just [ __ ] you know so just
like i criticized the uh the left or
progressive media or whatever the hell
they want to call themselves for being
for underrepresenting latinos
you look at some of the messages that
are coming out of the hard right media
and it's like guys come on i don't think
i don't think that's what they're saying
i don't think they're saying people are
going to come from mexico and they're
going to do this i think they're saying
these guys that
have a record of this san francisco why
are you letting them out again and again
and again and why are you doing that one
story i can show you statistics right
now that shows that not only are latinos
under indexing and crime in the united
states but they're actually like in last
place when it comes to committing crimes
and you know who commits the fewest
crimes
immigrants illegal immigrants as they
call themselves
they live in the shadows but every time
one undocumented immigrant has a dui or
has something front page easy
but wait a minute that's not the story
oh wait a minute okay so so go there so
go there so
if you're saying but they're doing the
same thing jorge ramos is doing but i
get that but what i'm saying but but the
difference is the messaging is
you don't need the government to take
care of you
ramos's message is univision television
you know all these other guys is hey we
need the government to do more for us no
you you need to go take your work ethic
and do something for yourself like you
did over there because you guys are
known for being hardest workers correct
so go do something with your life not
what was me let me go help you out all
this stuff like you said earlier
uh but but going there so you're a
little above but but but say the border
part just say the border part okay let's
talk about the border so
if you're saying illegal immigrants are
the least to commit crime in america
undocumented undocumented
okay so
why don't we just open the open up the
board and let everybody come up here and
i think that would be ridiculous and
stupid
right now wait a minute but why if
they're the least
to commit crimes let's just open it up
because they're the least to commit
crime well no i think the the the i was
using reductio absurdum to make a point
right i mean i'm using a logical
argument that says if you're going to
argue that the biggest problem we have
in america right now is we're about to
hit a recession because of inflation
which is caused by the supply chain
where we don't have any goods that are
made in this country how stupid is that
we can fix that overnight we have the
best workforce in the world right now
here latinos the best workforce in the
world they work two three jobs on
average the average non-latino in the
united states we could barely get them
to sign up for a job at target making 17
an hour right now so what does that tell
you we have a reliable capable workforce
that we are under using think of think
of a think like a business person that
we are under using and we could employ
them somehow by intelligently figuring
out how to get the right amount of
people over here from mexico or wherever
the hell so they can help our economy am
i saying does that mean oh just open the
border willy-nilly and let them all in
here including the badasses and the
pieces of crap obviously not i think
but neither party neither republicans or
democrats have sat down with the
exception of ronald reagan who was the
last guy to do this and say let's come
up with a cogent intelligent way of
being able to control the border by
allowing a certain amount of people in
based on the necessity of our country at
that time we can't even get that right
you know why because you said am i wrong
you said intelligent way to do it they
can't they can't intelligently find out
they can't and i just moved it from
california and what's happening there
there especially this administration's
attitude is just like just come come on
in and then i asked a question it's
everybody what is their goal are they
just telling these people hey listen
when they come in just remember we let
you in we didn't give a we didn't want
to vet you or anything vote democrat
that's what happens bro i i just left
the problem is neither party can come up
with a connection plan that works so you
know who's messaging you know who's
messaging to me is
extreme like i i i don't know if he has
any aspirations or not but the way he
gives his messaging is so freaking
attractive
to increase to to to improve a
population or community is a
pit bull the way pitbull talks about how
he was growing up listening to tony
robbins in the car with his mom driving
down and she was doing what she was
doing and he found a way to get out and
he did this and he did that in his
driving responsibility
that messaging is a very strong
messaging that the hispanic community
can
attach to versus hey
they don't do anything for us they don't
do anything for this first of all
america doesn't owe anybody anything i
agree okay but great you you use your
work ethic that you have you can do
anything you want to do in america
obviously there's you're not going to be
the next lebron james if you can't jump
46 inches but this is america or if your
dad didn't get you into harvard even
though you had a c average because he
was uh uh an alum there and has
connections so let's let's let's be
honest about this patrick there is
something to say about a country that
right now is allowing not the finest to
become successful but the ones who come
here with deep i know there's guys like
you and and me
i i came from poverty who are you
alluding to though who are you leading
to the guys that go to harvard like who
no i'm talking about i'm talking about
uh you know us wanting to make elon musk
a hero uh his dad owned a diamond mind i
mean come on let's face it he is that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean that he
grew up poor that doesn't mean he grew
up rich but
there is a difference to be fair between
a guy who comes to this country has to
really work his butt off to make it and
these guys who had it on easy street and
are looking at poor
river
you chose to come to this country go to
another country let me get this straight
so you just said you come to this
country
and this country
has to give you to the people that have
been here for a while it's like me
saying no no no no no no no you
misunderstood me that's what you're
saying no no no no what i'm saying is
advantage they should have an advantage
no no what i'm saying is that there's an
argument that still exists that there's
some things about our country that we
can fix to make sure everybody has an
equal plan it's not going to happen
though it's just not going to happen bro
and i'm telling you right now
and it doesn't have to
that simple it doesn't have to improve
look
for me
we came from iran to us the u.s gave us
a green card we came in u.s doesn't owe
me [ __ ] except for the green card they
gave me that's it i don't need to have
the same advantage or the same equal
opportunity as john f kennedy's grandson
i don't need to have that i agree yeah
so i agree so i am your story yeah my
parents about ten thousand dollars
combined yeah fewer poverty i get that
but that story needs to be told not the
story of we need to figure out a way to
make it equal it's not gonna happen yeah
it's not going to happen like well taken
it's just not for me to say hey it's
unfair that you know we need to make it
equal that lebron's kids can play
basketball because they're yeah i'm
totally okay with that i'm totally okay
with what if they're only five feet tall
but but the point so something like
shannon sharp says one time he says look
i understand the argument i was born
with this body yep i'm a bad i got a
badass body and it's it's unequal
opportunity to you and i versus shannon
sharp you look at the guy he's just got
it right so we're going to say hey work
out less hey do me a favor do a little
bit less legs can you run a little
slower can you no that's not this is how
it was created so for us to come here
and be able to compete
elon musk was an immigrant when he came
here and elon musk was able to build a
company and we should actually
get the kids again this goes back to a
conversation we had a few months ago
where we have to be careful who we
uh turn our turn into hero where our
kids aspire to be if we demonize
people that are heroes our kids don't
want to be like those people so let me
just say this yeah let me just say this
maybe maybe this is the way i should
present my argument pushing back on you
sure that it's all about yeah we're all
equal and everybody's the same and you
know we all get to the same place and
you know it's all about your merit which
i understand and if it's a meritocracy
and if it's truly a meritocracy i'm all
for it but if we live in a country where
a specific
company
can get subsidies from the government
because they lobbied certain politicians
and those politicians accepted the money
and then allowed that company to have an
advantage over my company
in a corrupt way
then we got to fix that
and some of that is happening in america
today well you're talking about lobbying
and corrupt uh i'm talking about if you
could just make the argument that
everybody no way that pat's gonna
disagree with you on that that's
something that is advocates against
non-stop
exactly two two weeks
six weeks ago i'm so against what the
lobbyists are doing but yeah exactly so
so we so all i'm saying is within our
system there are advantages for certain
people who have certain money okay those
are two different stories i took it out
of the immigrant basis
i get that what i think those are two
different stories what i think your
perspective is and and this is just me
you know sitting on your right for two
years now it's all you owe me once you
let me in the country is the opportunity
to succeed or fail yeah just you let me
in and you know they say nobody cares
work harder that's basically your
perspective no before you let me in
thank you it's on me now and pat you're
you're you're mama
that's his license right
they had to wait in line and they had to
wait till they get their card and they
came in here yeah right
yeah but by the way
we lived at a refugee camp for a year
and a half by the way you know that
everyone at this table has the same
story
my fa my family led uh fled eastern
europe in the 1920s and all settled here
in in america your family fled cuba his
family funded our parents came on a boat
exactly for 30 days immigration gets
complicated though guys and that's why i
keep going back to we need a system to
make it make sense because right now it
doesn't make sense and here's what
happens right now i'll give you an
example there's a company in dalton
georgia it is the carpet mill
manufacturing place of the entire world
when their workers all left or died or
got old from the appalachians who were
here from world war ii their kids said
dad mom i don't want to work at the mill
yeah i don't want that job so the entire
industry was about to dry up that
industry found a way to go to mexico and
recruit people who came to this country
to save the carpet mill industry which
is now thriving once again in dalton
georgia i went there and i talked to the
people in dalton georgia i said what do
you think of these people they said at
first we were very concerned but now you
know the guy who runs the dry cleaner
the guy who's a chamber of the chamber
of commerce guy says
they come into work earlier they leave
late they always pay their bills on time
they filled up our churches they're
great to have in this community so
and here is a company that illegally
went to mexico and recruited
undocumented immigrants to refill their
positions that americans apparently
didn't want
there's a story there that tells us
something i'm not sure what it is but i
think part of that story is the business
industry some people on the right or on
the left would say look at those people
those business people in dalton georgia
those bastards look what they did but
yet at the same time they help our
country become better by getting these
people here so we need a system that
allows the people of dalton georgia
those businesses to do that correctly
and legally i tell you what though i
think i think does that make sense yeah
but but i think the community that wins
there is the hispanic community because
so if people who are born in america
let's just say they're white and they
don't want to do the work of 17 bucks an
hour a target don't do it i'll do it
right i'll take that job it's totally
fine i'll take that job that's my dad
but here's the difference here's the
difference
the
in the military when you get out of the
military sometimes the challenge with
vets is
they get out they've been conditioned to
be government employees
and when they get out they've learned
work ethic they've learned to work
together as a team they've learned all
this stuff but they're small thinkers so
they get a job at the ups after they
come out of the military i made it hey i
get those additional 10 points on the
test i take hey i go become a cop hey
i'll go become a firefighter i'll go
become this i've made it and that's it
and that's all i do no problem
but you learned the most difficult thing
to be able to compete in marketplaces
which is working hard working as a team
in leadership that on free enterprise
can help you do a lot so the challenge
becomes hispanics are willing to do
those jobs you got to think a little bit
bigger and the hispanic voices like
yourself like the ramoses like those
people out there have to say hey why
don't you go compete with musk
instead of saying poor you you can't
compete with musk bo stop saying that i
can't stand it when people say stuff
like that to me when i was a kid coming
up because i'm supposed to be afraid of
somebody stop saying that kind of stuff
did i hit a nerve with this guy no no i
should not have said that the point the
only the point i'm trying i get your
point the point i'm like when i went to
india i went to indiana i spoke in india
four years ago five years ago and i'm
speaking at iit institute it's a it's
like they're mit which is an insane
school 5 000 people are sitting there
the chairman of a state bank of india
which is actually chairwoman arundhati
bashari 420 000 employees i believe they
have some 240 000 employees they have
then divyang turakia who's a young
billionaire him and his brother on the
cover of forbes and i'm speaking with
these guys and i said look here's a few
things here's what's about to happen you
guys got to realize you have a bigger
audience your average age is 24 25 26
you're the youngest china is 36 and
we're we're 36 china's 38 they're aging
you're not you're young you're learning
about capitalism you got a guy modi who
is letting you go out there and compete
in a few years decade or two there's
going to be someone showing up now that
you're rich you're wealthy your economy
is kicking everyone's ass to say
socialism the better way raise taxes all
these other policies going to start
making you feel sorry for yourself and
don't you can compete with everybody go
compete don't let any freaking news guy
politician any other person make you
feel you cannot so for me agree the
voices of the hispanic community the
leaders need to say hey what's so
special about elon musk go beat him
correct what's so special about this guy
go beat him what's so special about
obama go beat him be a president younger
than him instead of saying well you know
you know how it is it's not fair no no
no no go whoop their asses
because half the battle is somebody
believing in me that i can't pull it off
that's all it takes that's all i'm
saying so my eyes and you're right yeah
my idea is and that's by the way we are
exactly in the same place on that in
fact
the story you just told and the story of
cano health a story of a company that
started just five short years ago and is
now one of the leading value-based care
companies in the united states is a
story of latinos immigrants mexicans
cubans uh venezuelans puerto ricans
coming together and starting a company
and now doing what it has done where it
is the fastest growing healthcare
company in the united states so
it's exactly what you just said it's
just believing we could by the way your
story your story
that is a big inspirational story is the
following story
your story that is even bigger than what
you just talked about
is you chose to recreate yourself
just 15 years ago
whatever 12 i don't know the exact
timeline decade ago or so
you know hey big it you cannot believe
you said this fired hey you know the
anderson covetous hey this this
and then you chose to go and say okay
instead of being whoa oh my god feel
sorry for me no you know what i'm going
to go on free market i'm going to make
my money then i'm going to build a media
company then i'm going to show back up
because i got a message there is a value
in the message of choosing to recreate
yourself that recreating process you
seem very happy right now on the camera
i am sure behind closed doors there was
nights that was not too happy i'm sure
there was nights where you were really
like what the hell did i do wrong i'm
trying to be the guy that's bringing an
audience here so so you chose to
recreate you know and i think we can all
also recreate ourselves after a big
setback we had in our lives after cnn
fired me and not a single company would
even look at me and i called and they
would say god you're really talented and
you're very good on camera but
we just can't hire you and it got to the
point where we lost our house and uh the
children were you know having a tough
time and i remember
[Music]
at night
um
i didn't want my kids and my wife
to see me so i would go in a closet
and i would close the door
and i would cry
and i would try and figure out a way to
get out of it
and uh and what i did was i uh
i remade myself and i figured you know
if i can't be a journalist and it's all
i know
i'll be a cmo because
what i know as a journalist messaging
writing communicating is transferable
and there are people in america who
might be listening to the sound of my
voice right now who may have just lost
their jobs or maybe looking for
something else and they they need
somebody to tell them that they do have
the skills inside of them and they don't
need a handout and they don't need to
complain and they don't need to cry woe
was me
they just need to find those things
within themselves and then use those to
stretch themselves to do something
perhaps different than they've ever done
before
and that's what i did and uh
i i triangulated my brand and i went to
companies and they said
i'm rick sanchez i know how to do a
television show
and i also have a health care company
why don't you let us do a television
show on your station and you don't have
to pay me what you think you have to pay
me because i'm kind of desperate right
now but give me fifty percent of your
avails give me fifty percent of your
advertising whole we'll take that
advertising hall we'll fill it with our
commercials and that's how we grow our
company i think they're that uh
i think there needs to be more more
voices like you more people like like
like
we don't really hear that many stories
of the latino you know i'm saying
getting to that point there needs to be
more outlets like you saying these
stories so those those younger people
those 11 year olds that are coming up
can hear stuff like that and just like
like pat said it ain't a victim and then
whatever you could do whatever the hell
you want in this country there's no
there's no image holding you back
there's no like the man is just you stay
focused and you can do it if you can do
it then you're golden and he hit a court
when you said that pat you made me think
of those moments i mean that's that's
but that's the message though bro like
like we forget like how
shitty life was a decade ago and how
hard it was to recreate ourselves
recreating yourself as a form of saying
i'm not good enough for the next level
none of us like to say i'm not good
enough for the next level it's painful
it's emotional
it hurts our ego we have this
ego that's like this you know
material that's so flimsy that if it
drops it cracks in like we're all trying
to protect this ego of ours no but but
again tremendous respect for you to
doing what you've done to go from there
to being here
i i'm i'm very happy for you and i hope
you keep kicking ass and taking aqua to
uh different levels with the messaging
you guys are trying to do
uh
i'm glad you shared that with us by the
way appreciate you for doing that i was
great congrats to your success for going
from that closet crying to now being
where you are where you got your place
that you got and your family celebrating
it um and i know the feeling of what it
is to do the high five and say babe what
are we gonna do and boom you have the
choice to go out there and kick it and
just relax and you're saying no i'm
going to go lay some up and i want to go
for one more run that's hard to do when
you have money in the bank yeah yeah
yeah and i think but i mean rick sanchez
news is an opportunity for us to tell
the stories like the ones that you and i
are talking about now latinos are mules
we're mules that's what we call
ourselves that's what me and all my
latino friends we just want to work just
give me a chance to work give me a job
give me two jobs give me three jobs when
i first started after that
episode that i just shared with you guys
i had four jobs i started in the morning
teaching at my kids school so they
wouldn't kick them out of school because
i couldn't afford to have them there
uh american heritage uh then i uh belray
or the other campus the other campus
okay going over
and then i got a job working right
between rush limbaugh and uh sean
hannity uh for clear channel doing a
radio show awesome and then i would go
to
um
fox news hired me and said we're gonna
give you fox news latinos so they had me
doing that even though it wasn't really
up and running at the time and then i do
so basically i was picking up you know a
little bit here a little bit there and
then putting it all together to quite
try and equate what i was doing so
fantastic that's why agua media i think
is really important so check us out yes
real quick if we may i'm really
interested on this issue of immigration
because you you what we're doing now
obviously isn't working we're going to
have god knows how many numbers of of
illegal immigrants come across the
border under joe biden's presidency
we're at 2 million plus we just had the
50 that tragically passed away in san
antonio in the truck um and under
president trump you know refugees
admitted down by 65 temporary visas were
up five percent
but to be fair under president trump
those latinos that were coming over were
finally being paid what they deserved as
more illegals come over the wages fall
you can just fire one go get another one
cheaper pay them less pay less painless
so
we adam often talks about solutions what
is the solution because i think that
the motto that they're coming over
they're stealing our jobs is is
absolutely incorrect and let's not
forget about cesar chavez
the farm workers of america hated
absolutely hated illegal immigrants
right he would he would form a line and
beat him he would send them back what is
the answer to immigration what's the
actual solution i'm a businessman
i understand data
i understand how to do reporting that
gives you essentially a sense of how
you're growing your company
the united states should look at
immigration the way a businessman or
business woman
looks at their bottom line
how many do i need
what can they do
how many can i get how much do i have to
pay them and at any at any given time i
may have to lay off a few people or
bring in a few people and we've never
thought of treating the border and using
our data and our computers and our
ability to put all this information
together the same way that businesses do
instead we have these idiots these
[ __ ] morons in washington yelling at
each other trying to get votes saying
the other side is good the other side is
bad
all we've got to do is get the right
analysis the right number of analysts
data analysts the right number of
security expert to put that thing
together and we would have the thing
solved in a week but you know what to
really answer your question they don't
want to solve it
they don't want to solve it because the
moment they solve it they lose one of
their arguments both sides including
both the democrats and the republicans
that's how i would argue that i think
that's i think that's correct your audio
is low can we increase tyler's audio a
little bit uh but let's let's go to the
next story let's just go to a story now
joe rogan okay let's uh let's address
that story i don't know if you guys are
following it or not if you saw what he
said yesterday
uh about uh he was asked about
interviewing trump yeah on lex friedman
podcast so joe rogan reveals if he will
ever host donald trump on his podcast
despite hosting a uh
uh a group of polarizing figures on his
show post uh pot steering podcaster joe
rogan claimed there's one person who
he'll never oh who'll never appear on
this podcast former president of donald
trump the 54 year old comedian and ufc
commentator was candid during a monday
episode on joe oregon experience with
computer scientist lex friedman i'm not
a trump supporter in any way share shape
or form the former fear factor host told
friedman i have the opportunity to have
him on my show more than once and have
said no every time he added i don't want
to help him i'm not interested in
helping him so what do you think about
this story with joe rogan well well he
was on the lex for even podcast right
and that's where he's i think the the
whole thing and you've been on rogan we
you know
you were texting him yesterday as we
were discussing the story that's the the
ironic part but
the thing with joe is i don't think joe
is left or right i think if
like bernie sanders has been on a show
as far left as as it gets in america
today
as far right as it gets as he has alex
jones on the show he finds common ground
with everybody that's the beauty of joe
rogan is that he could sit there be
completely empathetic to you listen
actively listen he's not there to
for ratings or to pander he's just
actively listening and
it's funny when you watch joe if you're
a little bit further left
and you start he was like yeah i agree
with you i agree with you totally and
then if you're a little bit further
right he'll sit there and constantly
agree with you he's very fluid there's
nothing he's not a hardliner on anything
that's the beauty of joe and then
speaking of left i mean he came from
hollywood
you know comedy scene you the comedy
said he would vote for bernie sanders
yeah but then on on the right side of
things like he does ufc he's tight with
dana white like that's on the right side
but you know what he's saying adam with
this what i see hurting me for
interrupting but what i see what i hear
when he says that is that he's living in
a silo
and what we need are fewer silos in
america right what do you mean he's
living in a silo silo is a place where
you're only with your own group like a
bubble bro
but hold on let me just be any further
from
but let me just finish silo no no
obviously
he's in i know joe rogan and i know that
he's interviewed all kinds of people but
when you make the statement i don't want
to interview the former president of the
united states you're basically saying to
me i don't want to be associated with
that guy i don't even want to hear what
he has to say and i think that that's
right he doesn't want to give him his
platform that's what he's saying but
because in the context of what he's
saying but in the context of what he's
saying he was talking about joe biden
actually it was it had nothing to do
with trump on the lex freeman podcast he
was basically saying
joe biden is a walking dead man
and that
he is that's who he was talking about
and then he was referencing if you
actually saw the clip did you see it
no all right so let me inform you he was
talking about biden and then basically
biden being on kimmel and basically
saying dude someone stopped this guy
like he's just rambling let's take it
hear me out though rick go hear me out
go ahead
and then he alluded to the fact by the
way it was almost like a ps by the way
as i'm [ __ ] on joe biden just
understand something i'm not a trump guy
i'm not trying to give trump a platform
i'm just letting you know where i stand
right i've had the opportunity to
interview trump multiple times i've
declined
that's the context of what it was what
you was in he alluded to the fact that
and then they went on talking about
listen i give alex jones a platform this
guy is a quote-unquote far uh right-wing
far-right nut job and he goes you know
in actuality alex jones is right ninety
ninety percent of the time yes he got it
wrong about um
and all that yeah and he got in trouble
for it basically the bottom line is he
was [ __ ] on joe biden and he used
hyperbolic language about him not
wanting to affiliate with trump to
basically show hey look as bad as i
think biden's doing i'm not a trump guy
it was [ __ ] on biden but it took the
all i'm saying is if you're a host and
you're given an opportunity to interview
the former president united states you
should probably 100 i agree and if you
don't interview the president united
states you're saying something about
yourself that you're living in a certain
place where you're not letting in a
certain kind of thinking perhaps i'm not
saying i know that trump is a vile dude
and has done some really vile stuff but
that doesn't mean that if he's a former
president you don't give him his
opportunity and ask him the tough
questions and if he wants to get up and
walk out he walks out but i just
disagree with the notion of saying i
would never interview a former vice
president i agree i agree with that's
all i'm saying i agree with all the
disagreement because trump we talked pat
when i walked in here trump was recently
on uh full send podcast with a couple of
young guys one of my friends bob mentes
on there and uh it got banned what two
days it was kicked off it's like i just
want to hear what this person has to say
yeah without getting like listen as
crazy as it is say what i don't give a
[ __ ] what anybody's opinion have your
opinion but for joe roll gonna be like
nah i'm not going to support him you're
not supporting him i want to be able to
hear because they're not going to
abandon on spotify we'll actually get to
hear the entire interview let me hear
what you have to say i interviewed fidel
castro you think that was easy i
interviewed gordon
i'll interview xi jinping i'll interview
putin i'll interview uh bodhi i'll
interview
is there anybody our job as a journalist
is to do that is there anybody you
wouldn't interview
there's anybody that you wouldn't want
to give a bigger platform a microphone
no so there's nobody that you no truth
is fresh air i mean that's what we do i
mean if
you know patrick and i have had
disagreements during this conversation
respectful disagreements we're both men
we can have a disagreement and walk away
and shake hands if you can't do that
with another human being i think that's
kind of on you and i also think
journalistically speaking it kind of
degrades the field so but that's my
opinion would you reveal what you
said the joke or texted him so
what he just said
he doesn't have to live to those
standards in his eyes because you said
journalistic integrity
i don't think he sees himself as a
journalist fair i think he sees himself
as this is my show it's my podcast i
talk who i want to talk to
where on the what
unfortunately
guilty by association joe has become a
journalist i think so and but you know
you know the book accidental millionaire
they wrote about jobs in wozniak jose
this is actually a good title for a book
if he writes it accidental journalist
okay this is how he accidentally became
the most powerful journalist in america
some may call it in the world okay on
the kind of influence that he has so
you know but does that mean
he has to meet the standards of what the
journalistic standards are he doesn't
have to do it good question does that
mean it's going to upset his audience
sure the audience that would love to see
him
push trump back but at the same time
you ever seen the video when joe is
teaching
gsp
how to put so much power into his kick i
don't know if you've ever seen this
video it's like a four minute clip and
joe's ki and joe's kicks like a beast
first of all he's teaching
gsp who some consider him one of the top
five goats of all time
and he's teaching gsp how to do this
kick but the way he's teaching
the level of precision in his teaching
one cannot be extremely technical and
meticulous and detailed and strategic
without being able to teach a kick the
way he teaches i know this makes no
sense but in my mind joe knows what he's
doing 100 joe knows what he's doing
listen i wouldn't be surprised if a
desantis a newsome and a michelle obama
on his podcast the next six to 12 months
i think so too so
i wouldn't be surprised if those guys
are uh gonna be on there i think you
know he made positive comments about
desantis a week ago or two weeks ago
when he said i think desantis would be
president so a week after that he says
that about trump
maybe he feels desantis is going to be
the right guy to be the president and
maybe he wants to get behind the santas
and if he wants to do that that's his
guy are you power to him but wait did
you just say that joe rogan uses his uh
microphone to influence political
thought in america that he might be that
whether he likes it or not he has been
doing that because that's very
machiavellian i mean if he says i'm
going to say today that trump is a
bad guy that i'm not going to interview
but and tomorrow i'm going to say
desantis is a great guy that's
alien and by the way i'm not criticizing
he could do that he said desantis is a
great guy a week ago he said the
sentence he made the comments about the
sentence a week ago when he said i think
the santos would make a great president
yeah and then on this one he says i
would never have trump on the podcast uh
and by the way he's consistently stating
the same position about trump for a
while he's not a
he saw trump as an entertainer he saw
trump he called him teflon nothing
bothers him all this stuff and he
handles it you know he handles the
criticism that it comes but you know i'm
sure he's had many chances to have trump
on he hasn't had him on but it's
interesting the only thing i'm saying is
maybe
he
kind of wants to influence the next
election and by the way to to be honest
with you i think this next debate that
comes up
uh all these other guys who are you
going to get you're going to get wallace
you're going to get who i think the i
think the media is dumb
if they don't realize that the next the
stop the media is done yeah the the next
debates have to be held by guys like
you know podcast form where guys can
give a 10-minute answer 15-minute answer
20-minute answer and set a two-minute no
american voter wants a two-minute answer
they've proven they don't mind
three-hour podcast america's
not just a million people
hundreds of millions of people worldwide
have said we are very comfortable with
three-hour podcast so those of us in
journalism school were taught about
agenda setting i mean agenda setting is
what journalists do and it's crap and i
couldn't agree with more with what you
just said patrick because unfortunately
more often than not they set that agenda
during those debates so the candidates
don't get an opportunity to be real or
talk about things that matter or even
talk about things that matter to the
american people they get to talk about
things that have been chosen or screened
by those members of the media the meet
the press [ __ ] right so you know uh
that's not really the conversation that
america wants to hear i could not agree
with you more
do a free-for-all get three or four
people give them a certain amount of
time let them go after each other and
i'll i'll come away with a perspective
and by the way it we say this all the
time on the podcast we hear it from
political figures and pundits whether
it's people on the far right or the
right side roger stone paul manafort
to uh people on the left like jenk
wieger or andrew yang people have been
all and they say
what a refreshing opportunity to sit
down and just talk
for a couple hours where it's like all
right mr biden you're on the clock two
minutes and then
204 and he's like i think i should stop
talking now
the the the debate format of this
country is getting stale and old and the
podcast format going back and forth for
a couple of hours is the new thing i
love rick just really fast not to go off
subject but you were talking about the
whole agenda and the political driven
type of would from cnn point because you
used to work at cnn what did was it
always that type of obviously they have
a side but like from what you saw during
like you know the trump and the four
years of trump was what was the
difference that you thought from that
like was it the same type of attitude
like
does that hardcore just like it gets
destroyed it got so personal over there
first of all they put the guy in office
right they gave him more media time than
any candidate in the history of the
united states yeah they thought it would
be funny to put this goofball every time
he had a debate or something on camera
because that's how they saw him they
thought he was yeah
it's good tv and every time they had him
on his ratings went up so jeff bush
would have a news conference and they
would take him for 30 seconds uh and
trump knew that so he would create
opportunities for you to reap what you
saw exactly but then when it happened
yeah they've got they've got their uh
their their cmo their uh their
zucker who's got a relationship with
trump so now all of a sudden it becomes
personal and now they start attacking
the guy every day for anything including
the russia thing which was crap
and then they end up with egg on their
face and now where the hell are they
that's why they're trying to figure
themselves out for their ratings we are
amazing we said this we said this the
other day we had the podcast they better
pray because i'm gonna send msnbc and
all these numbers are down they better
pray to god that he wins again they
better because then they'll have more
[ __ ] to talk about because nobody's
watching i wish they would go out and
just hire journalists and do journalism
again because they once did that back in
the 1980s and they were pretty good at
it but today they don't hire journalists
they hire people who politically look
good on tv or political activists or
actors i mean cuomo for example i mean
i'm sure he's a perfectly good guy but i
mean what the hell is he doing doing a
television show because his brother is
the governor you get a television show
anderson cooper used to be uh the host
of a uh reality show
i could go down the list of people who
are not journalists but are wearing the
badge of journalists let me know that's
not what we should be doing in this
country as a journalist you've been a
journalist for my whole life 40 years
yeah all right it didn't this this whole
lack of integrity and lack of
professionalism and ethics we talk about
what a journalism what a journalist
needs to be doing
it didn't start the downfall of
journalism didn't start with trump where
do you think that started like you got
cancelled in 2010. that's crazy where
did the where did the lack of being a
real journalist where did that really
what was the tipping point to be real
honest with you it happened the day they
invented ratings that came in every 15.
the nielsen ratings or what yeah when
you can actually tell
and have data on i had a dancing monkey
on or i did a story about a dancing
monkey and my ratings went through the
roof so from now on i'm going to do a
lot of dancing when was that uh it was
like in the late 1980s and the beginning
of the 1990s where they really perfected
audience research so we could know
exactly to the moment and to the word
what you got back like if we only did
this show based on the data says we have
to talk today about the you know
whatever styrofoam cups so we've got to
introduce a topic about styrofoam cups
and they have to do it exactly five
minutes when people who livestock like
styrofoam cups are watching so the
moment that the data took over the
message the message became beautiful and
that correct me if i'm wrong that's sort
of around the time when we went from
having the big three abc nbc cbs to all
of a sudden cnn is a thing 10 turtle
starts that or roger ailes
rupert murdoch start uh fox in the 90s
brilliant adam think it through so you
have data collection become a big part
of how we do news you've got really
smart business people out there who then
start getting into the business and
saying well if we can control the data
we can control the flow we control the
flow we control the audience size we
control the audience as we control the
ratings control the money control the
profits control the revenue once they
did that very
wealthy people came in and took huge
swaths of the journalism outlets on them
which then you know concentrated the
amount of good journalism that was out
there and that's how we got to work but
isn't that capitalism i mean do we have
a problem with that like i i'm let me
just if you're not familiar with rick
and one of the famous i remember saying
i asked the buddy of mine i'm like i got
rick sanchez coming to the pod oh
you remember what rick chancellor
sanchez was famous for what if it bleeds
it leads that's right remember that
whole thing that's right it bleeds it
leads so like it's part of the part of
media where it's like okay let's go
compete we're cnn we're fox right i'm a
journalist we get a we got a journalist
who's now a businessman so i understand
both parts of it and i'm
tussling with it
you know patrick i'm sure will tell you
as a guy who's been very successful in
business you got to go with that it take
takes you right we're in the eyeball
business baby i mean you know what it is
at the same time has that data been a
positive for
what is
proper information for the american
people probably not
that there's there's there's the you
know you know what i think you know what
i think is winning today though i think
uh the reason why joe is winning joe is
real i think why these podcasters are
winning because they're real
and what what their stone what the what
the mainstream media is paying a price
for is they're starting to realize
if you constantly remember john kerry
had a shot at winning being a president
and then he went and gave one switch one
speech one place and next week he gave a
completely different message and they
said what a flip-flopper and then boom
he lost he should have been the
president by the way he's part of the
skull and bones and
yale and all that stuff and him in bush
and he's supposed to be a president
kerry
and he lost he looks like he looks like
lincoln if you look at him and then
height all that stuff he just looks
president
president he looks presidential so what
did american voters say yeah we we we
don't like that we don't mind if you
change your mind but we don't like you
trying to
deceive us and go from here to there to
that we're not a fan of that so
you know and today america is just flat
out saying hey are you real
i don't care if i agree with you or not
but are you real okay cool hey bill
maher seems real i don't agree with them
but he's real i value that russell
brandt seems real i don't agree with
them but i value that hey joe rogan
seems real i don't know if i agree with
them but i value that we are starting to
show
that there's a lot of value in the
currency of being
real right there's a lot of value in the
currency of being able to reason and
have a disagreement with somebody that
you but you're able to sit down and have
like we're valuing those things which is
a great thing by the way
those currencies being valued again it's
a fantastic thing because it forces
everybody to be what
uh i identify that you have some flaws
you have some weaknesses you ain't
perfect and that's the american vote the
american vote relates to that they don't
relate to the perfect person that's
looking perfect no no no we don't relate
to you bro yeah we relate to these other
guys that are flawed and by the way what
does it matter they're in a dying
industry right so
whatever they do they're saying legacy
media
whatever whatever you we were just
talking about with cnn and all that it's
almost they're irrelevant so what does
it matter what they're doing their
audience is 70 years old yeah but some
of them are being smart enough and
they've already done it made them move
to youtube already i mean box presence
on youtube is massive what what i mean
what will matter is is valuetainment
that's what will matter agua media will
matter joe rogan will matter the future
of media is these types of expressive
conversations
until something maybe comes along and
pollutes us and makes us lose our way
well and and that's my point follow the
money ftm i mean so basically what pat's
saying is keeping it real that's the
reason that rogan's got a voice that's
the reason that we've got a voice it's
the reason that alex jones has got a
voice these third-party young turks has
got a voice cause at least keep it real
because i feel like with the legacy
media and you could speak to this better
than anyone probably on this panel
is that whether you're on fox or whether
on cnn i feel like if you pull back the
curtain wizard of oz style it's actually
this entire podcast this private
platform is brought to you by
allegra big pharma who just gave you 10
trillion dollars to advertise so like
that's the part of keeping it real
in legacy media and mainstream media
it's like
what's really happening behind the
scenes is who's really paying the bills
and that's what it comes down to i think
that's why people don't distrust
mainstream media no patrick's right
people need to get a sense that they're
hearing you yeah you your gut so check
this out so so california right now is
going through what they're going through
and
you know i feel something happened in
the last couple of weeks
where the democratic party had a meeting
with the obamas the pure speculation
happened this is not insider information
i know nothing i'm just speculating
because they suddenly
went from obama's to newsom okay they
suddenly went from obama to newsom
so has it been a conversation to try to
convince michelle to run or not i don't
know
was it an idea to say
highest q score for a woman that if she
runs one of the highest q scores she can
win slam dunk etc etc and she says i
just don't want that life now they're
thinking who do we have to prep because
biden's not going to be running it ain't
going to be kamala america does not like
kamala i haven't even heard what is she
doing and america doesn't like kamala
they don't like kamala more than they
don't like biting like if they don't
like biting kamal is beating biting and
likability right i think you may be
right but michelle may have said no
and they said no and they said who's the
next person they have to go and draft
the next person they're like hey let's
get newsom so let's spin the story
what's the story
well didn't they try to recall newsom no
the fact that he won by 63 vote it just
shows that's who america wants it just
shows that's exactly who america wants
america wants a new son america wants a
winner like him and they're gonna spin
that right the spinning marketing game
is taking place and this whole thing
with what happened with lgbt i don't
know if you guys saw the story or not
which is
very interesting that so he goes and
takes a vacation where so this guy goes
uh yeah california governor newsom
enjoys montana vacation despite lgbtq
state travel ban that's a new york post
story california's democratic governors
are joined some rnr in montana this week
despite big sky country being the one of
20 states
to which the golden state bar uh bars
officials state funded travel over laws
deemed discriminatory against lgbtq it
was revealed tuesday that newsom had
gone to montana where his in-laws own a
ranch and was expected back
at work july 11 in response newsome
spokesperson anthony york tweeted the
travel ban applies to using state funds
the governor's travel is not being paid
by the state connecting the two is an
attempt at gotcha journalism that is
neither gotcha nor journalism the
governor is on vacation with his family
he will return later this week uh
despite york statement it was unclear
whether newsome and his family were
accompanied by security on their visit
on how the security was paid for if they
were there so
these types of stories that are coming
out what's going on with uh montana
another story with when he went to
french laundry a little bit of hypocrisy
exactly
you say you're for this then why are you
going over here and the other side is
who gives a [ __ ] where the guy wants to
go on vacation
yeah you want to use state funded stuff
but all i'm saying is
you know i have a feeling the party
it's like when you're an nba team and
you were hoping to land durant and you
don't get durant and you get stuck with
lu dang you know you get stuck with
somebody you're like [ __ ] i gotta take
that 21 million your contract for three
years because there's nothing else in
the market people are trying to land
michelle they don't have michelle
newsome maybe the candidate for 2024.
here let me give you the what we're
going to be voting for
pence chaney
versus newsome michelle
really excuse me pence pants for
president pence cheney there's some
stories that just started
filtering out
late yesterday afternoon that i started
reading
where
republican donors are going to start
according to some of my sources making a
pitch for matching pence
on top of the ticket
cheney liz on the bottom of the ticket
because they are over the trump drama
and they need two people who are going
to be able to solidify the republican
party and that's the direction they're
drawing there's no way that trump will
rick i know that you don't believe that
you're citing a story
like i almost got hung a couple weeks
ago
so what happens if the establishment
pushes that there's no establishment
anymore the establishment's gone it's a
donald trump it's the maga party but
you're underestimating the power of the
donors in america i'm not i think you're
understanding the power of america
and i'm not a trump guy
they've got zero pull in that party
anymore the maybe within washington at
the corridor
pence cheney's got no
pull with who the voters
the donors
all right let me read this here 20 24
ticket vice president pence shane
wyoming liz jenny might just be the
thing that saves the republican party
and our republicans donald trump's
descent in a golden escalator in 2015.
there are has been too many others on
republicans who don't know again okay so
great fine if you want to say that then
tell us why trump is 141 and 11 with his
endorsement
he was killing it so why why should
listen
desantis if he runs he's got a shot i
agree
michelle runs
high
high chance of winning as the face not
as a vp as the face if she runs
if if michelle and newsome run michelle
lead knew some
she would have to win the nomination
that'd be interesting if that were to
take place this would be not so toxic by
the way obviously oh pennsylvania pence
cheney is not it doesn't never happen it
would never happen it's just the same
way people were saying kasich would not
be toxic
kasich was a you know good guy he's not
a number one yeah uh biden won not
because he's a number one biden at best
is a
you know who should he was the director
of operations yeah he would be he's not
even put there by the party yeah he was
put there by the party to go up against
you know a uh trump but uh do least
damage
that doesn't sound like you see that i
just don't see pence cheney i don't see
that at all yeah i don't see them coming
out of the republican primary and i
don't see democrats being like okay
we're going to take our pence guy that's
it's i guess the argument is they want
to go back to the middle right and uh
yeah is there but to your question which
is a really astute question adam is
is there enough juice in the middle to
be able to support something like i had
i had a conversation with i remember our
friend joe he's gonna be he's gonna
cry when he hears this part of the
podcast i called him we called him on
the phone
and i said joe this guy is maggot out
trump like rush limbaugh is his hero
and i said who do may he rest in peace
yeah
uh who do you and on speaking on behalf
of the maga community the trump
community
hate more
democrats or rhinos he goes it's not
even close
what do you think his answer was
he goes
we cannot stand
the
the toe the line republican rhinos it's
not the mitt romney's of the world the
liz cheney's of the world the adam
kinzingers of the world
and now somehow pence i guess is in that
world now because he's out of mega world
i guess
he goes
because at least democrats as wrong as
they are have a freaking spine and a
backbone they're wrong but they stand up
he goes those people will bend for
anything this was his perspective
interesting he's basically saying that
and i think most republicans are mega
now but if that's those people are
dinosaurs in the republican party but
the republican party for reagan the
republic republican party that was no
longer exists it's trump's party it's a
maga party and we'll reap what they sow
but if that's the case guys then what
will happen if there are enough
donors for starters who seem to be
according to some of the stories that
we're seeing filter that they're a
little concerned because the january 6
committee hearings that they're trying
to take their money away from trump that
they're going to start giving the money
to desantis and to
uh pence and two liz cheney whoever the
hell they choose
what happens to the party does it
disintegrate i mean what happens to the
republican party if if that feuds same
thing that's happening to the democratic
party because the democratic party is
also divided between the socialists and
the democrats it's it's a
you know
maybe even in three different categories
the democratic party you got the
socialists you got the democrats and you
got the tulsa gabbard and the andrew
yank community because neither andrew
yank nor tulsi are democrats they're
more center left uh then you have the
traditional democrats say biden hillary
yeah you know obama's all that then you
have the
socialist democrats
you know we've already seen this for the
democratic party with nader ralph nader
that's the party and cost them the
election right will that now happen in
the republic that was what 2000 that was
bush
nader right 2000 right yeah so so the
question here for us is is that about to
happen i just don't think there's any
appetite for pence at the top of a
ticket how many people how many people
how many followers does lincoln project
have no i follow not not twitter
followers but i mean how many how many
how many followers from lincoln project
to say come up with a candidate and i'll
vote for you how big is lincoln
project's influence that's what you got
to be thinking about i think to the
point tyler's point is that it's the
their influence is with you know what
people with money go to socialblade go
to socialblade.com go to socialblade.com
and yeah right there and and go up top
and type in
a link in project yeah lincoln project
you just may want to spell it right uh
there it is okay so this is what this is
their youtube channel
uh go up a little bit go up a little bit
the way you were going i'm sorry go down
go down go down go down go down go down
go down down okay there you go
yeah they're not getting a lot of views
now watch when the channel got started
by the way very weird when they started
the channel go all the way to the top
it says what date it's january 6th crazy
2020. now
go to uh uh weird right it's a year
before when it happened actually because
it's not the that's very crazy
yeah now go to the lincoln project and
see their twitter handle so put the same
thing in
except go to twitter okay go to twitter
and type in lincoln project
the lincoln
project
uh
you spelled pro cop
take your time that the it's got a queue
in it buddy just write slow t-h-e
tyler's name
project there you go twitter click uh
okay you have to put the whole hand on
behalf of blackboard media we thank you
for bringing me this copy of the show
thank you very much you got to put the
whole thing together spell the whole
thing together and you'll see where i'm
going with this
just put their twitter handle which is
what project lincoln okay
it's called project linking so go over
the perfect there you go go to social
plate
type in project link in
press search go up
go up go go keep going down okay so
check this out you know what that is let
me tell you what that is
forget about that at 2.7 million
they're not gaining followers today no
so meanings no one gives a [ __ ] about
them today that means it's over cheney
and pence don't stand a chance at
winning because if that was
five thousand a day eight thousand a day
nine thousand thirty eight dollars in
trouble
dude that's the last two weeks look at
the last two weeks right look at matter
of fact go to 30 days go up a little bit
and go to 30 days and you can actually
increase that to uh detailed statistics
go to the top and click on detail
statistics
so go lower it'll give you 30 days
that's 30 days look at that one for at
2.7 million better twitter accounts
going up like
patrick let me let me push back
but by the way
while he's doing this pull up aoc while
he's doing this pull up aoc go ahead if
we are going to agree that the politics
in america is very much donor driven and
money
as we've learned with joe biden who was
probably the least competent candidate
even among the republican
pardon me the democratic field which was
very weak to begin with right but
somehow the party the donors the money
pushed him to the top above everybody
else then could we not assume that it
doesn't really matter at this point how
many people you got because once the
money kicks in this could all change all
right let me tell you let me just show
you this here look at that that's my
argument i'm going to respond back to
that look at this here go up and show
them who this is we're looking at a girl
named aoc i don't know if you've heard
her she's pretty famous aoc
13.19 million followers let's see how
she's doing the last 30 days
look at that keep going up 36 000
followers in a day 22 000 followers in a
day
lincoln project their her worst day
isn't their best 30 days combined wow
combined okay wow that's a threat this
is a real threat of people wanting to
now go type in desantis let's see how
the census is doing told you she's gonna
be president so so i don't think cheney
and um
pence can beat desantis
i don't think cheney and pence can be
trump
i think they're uh remember when there
was a guy named scott walker well scott
walker is going to be wisconsin
boom a month later oh no governor perry
no so you have to have charisma nowadays
you have to have charisma and who do you
think would be more attractive uh aoc or
gavin newsom he's growing aoc or newsom
well
you're saying now she's not she can't no
i'm not even i'm saying physically
physically yeah
but good-looking couple can i can i say
one thing about the lincoln project
because this speaks to the exact same
reason that cnn ratings are tanking and
like nb's taking and exactly what vinnie
essentially talked about is all roads
lead to trump that's it okay the reason
that lincoln project is fleeting and
there's no because trump's out of office
their whole point of lincoln project was
the they're a never trump movement right
they got him on office yeah all right
guys let's the band's done right the
whole point of cnbc sorry msnbc and cnn
was talk about trump talk about trump
let's get him out of office he's the
worst now he's at office look at your
rankings look at your rating so i'm not
shocked by anything like this this is
the all roads lead back to trump and
that's essentially my point is with
pence and
liz cheney
these are afterthoughts let's go to
another story so teachers
in florida okay uh paid seven largest
teachers union
florida's 9 000 teachers short for the
upcoming
year this is a uh
let me see this story here
uh largest teacher 9 000 short in the
state of florida industry experts say
the problem is pretty simple nobody
wants to be a teacher anymore for
multiple reasons it seemed less and less
like a viable fulfilling career option
the regional director of teach for
america said the solution is simple take
steps to make teaching an attractive
career once again a florida education
association report has shown more than 9
500 teaching
and support staff positions across the
state of florida are vacant it says the
shortage is so wild wide-ranging that
more than 450 000 florida students
may have started last school year
without full-time certified teachers in
their classroom a survey of high school
students found that only five percent
were interested in becoming teachers and
that survey was from four years ago what
do you think is going on here with these
teachers i am
i think it speaks to
where we are and i hate to go back to
the same thing but
that's a great gig
that's a great gig that's a nice job
that's an honorable profession no money
it's fun
it's it's you're you're changing lives
and if we're at a place in this country
where we can't get people to want to
take a decent
job yeah you're not going to make a lot
of money i mean
if you're latino you're making a lot of
money yeah i remember once
i was listening to um god who's the big
tall guy who used to be on fox news he
and i used to go at it all the time uh
o'reilly right
bill o'reilly and i remember
he went on he was interviewed once and
he said i grew up i grew up poor in
america my dad was a a postman he was
the the letter carrier you know mailman
as we used to call him
um
and i thought to myself
that's poor
as a latino my dad my dad cleaned
toilets at the barcelona hotel on miami
beach and in the daytime he was also
working as a busboy and then he had a
job driving a truck at night
bill that's what my dad did stop telling
people that because your dad is a
mailman you grew up poor because you
certainly didn't grow up poor
this mindset not to pick on you vinnie
because i love you like a brother pero
this mindset that oh my god she's a
teacher she doesn't make a lot of money
that's damn good money they make 30 40
50 000 i don't care that's that's pretty
good money you could make a living and
you could raise a family out of that but
it was a couple i don't know people want
these jobs is what i'm saying pat
they're underappreciated they don't like
do the teacher i think is is one of the
most important things to give people
dude teachers made us and we talked
about it they don't get they don't get
the acknowledgement they don't get the
credit and i'm sorry 30 40 50 000 in
this in this day and age is nothing and
they i think it's like you said they're
reinventing and they're moving a certain
way
i know a lot of latino friends of mine
who would die for thirty five thousand
dollar job and by the way if you wanna
be appreciated tell them like work in
florida if you wanna be appreciated get
a dog okay just you know
you know you got an opportunity to do
something you got an opportunity to make
a difference you get to go to work sit
in a place that's air-conditioned every
day affect people's lives and you're
going to say no that's beneath me come
on there's something wrong with our
country if that's been easy rick there's
a lot of latinos in florida one of you
guys become teachers
tighter exactly why do you think this is
happening
anything outside of what we've said
why do you think this is happening
it's interesting i mean you look at um
you look at the people that are becoming
teachers now and they're more and more
activists they're more and more focused
on themselves they want to project their
beliefs onto kids they want to you know
it's like you see
libs of tick tock is a funny one but
really look at the the average teacher
who's teaching kids now coming out of
college they're activists they're not
interested in
helping the youth grow and really
educate and help them learn they're
interested in indoctrinating them and i
think there's
i think there's been an interesting
loss of that idea of actually educating
not just indoctrinating not just pushing
beliefs but actually teaching somebody
something history uh the great classic
works i mean how to
be a better person i mean like really
true education
and i think
there's such an interest in myself
pushing what i believe pushing my
personal desires onto people that yeah
you know you know what i'm you know i
kind of butchered it but if it makes
sense i mean there's a few ways i i i
think about this one if this is the if
you think about 9 000 teachers to me
how many students per teacher is it fair
to say 30 i'd say 30. okay so that's 270
000 kids right if you think about it
there's 270 000 kids if it's 9 000
teachers short so are you doing the
numbers to see what it is
uh one in 15 is that what it is in you
in florida okay so 9015 135 so let's say
150 to 300 000 students are being
affected by this okay so how do you
handle this do you handle it by
giving a bump do you handle it by
lowering the requirement to be a teacher
do we get the data to see these 9 000
student 9 000 teachers that is shortage
is it in elementary is it in junior high
is it in high school
what's the breakdown what's the
definition of a teacher could it be
kindergarten how are they processing
this
and then if you're thinking about the
future of education does this mean the
education route has to be changed is it
more online is it more homeschooling
what direction is this going to be going
because
a lot of these types of stats that you
see is a byproduct of
certain you know laws certain new
guidelines rules a direction certain
industry is going where people say i
just want to don't i don't want to do
this job i'd be so interested to know
more of the data
of what category these 9 000 teachers
are in
i'd be curious to know
but to me nine thousand i i don't know
how far the story is going to go how
much more we're going to hear that give
you some data yeah so we want to go data
with it so what percentage of teachers
do you think are women
most
75 percent of women majority okay so and
the average age of a teacher is 42 years
old yeah so if i'm a woman and i'm in my
early 30s mid 30s
42 is the average
and i'm looking and i'm seeing what's
going on all around me on you said the
libs of tick tock right all right so if
i'm a attractive kindergarten teacher
and i'm making 42 grand a year
and i'm overworked i'm underpaid yeah i
get the summers off that's cool and i'm
looking around and i'm going down the
conspiracy rabbit hole here but i'm a
young attractive woman
and i see what's going on at girls on
only fans and covid and lockdown and
masks and kids and snot and flu and
covid
and
becky down the street is uh doing only
fans 250 dollars yeah exactly just
printing money you're showing off her
and she's like you know what [ __ ] this
i'm out
i'm gonna go do something else i'm gonna
go i'm not saying they're only in the
room what school did you go to where
every female teacher was high there's
some i'm just saying sorry what seven
did you go to like
hooters junior high school
obviously you didn't meet mrs mcelveen
you know i grew up
most teachers are females and they're
just like
but if you're if we've got but if we
come over this nonsense if we've gotten
to a point in this country where you're
going to turn down as i'm reading here
an average salary starting salary in the
state of florida between forty four
thousand and fifty one thousand dollars
because some ideal and the summer's off
as you said because you have some oh i
don't like the way they're saying this
or i don't like the way they're doing
that i don't know man what do you mean
like they don't like the way they're
saying well whatever whatever it is that
they don't like they don't like the fact
that the
the whatever the political argument of
the moment is i mean
my gosh it still seems to me like you're
passing up on a hell of an opportunity
yeah you know so what does that say
about our society that people don't need
that job once again the rick sanchez
agua media message we need more mexicans
well
what does it say about our society is
that people don't want to work hard
anymore they'd rather get really quick
they'd rather pump their money into
bitcoin or don't worry bro or sit around
and do a
uh uh only fans video why would you want
to go to work
work your ass off dealing with
snot-nosed kids to make 40 grand a year
when you could just turn on a video cam
at home and do only fence i know that
that's an extreme example right but
that's the reality a lot of people want
to get rich quick and not have to work
hard and that's unfortunately the
reality yeah either way it's uh it's a
sad commentary on the times we live in
america right now when you look at some
numbers like that so
so next story i'm gonna go page five
this has to do with oil and gas which if
this story is true this is a very
annoying story so here we go so biden
allowed five million barrels from
national reserve to go abroad this is a
daily mail story
uh he shipped five million barrels from
the united states to uh strategic orders
abroad uh after claiming that releasing
them would help ease americans pain
at the pumps the president faces
accusations of a sneaky slight of hand
as it was revealed that between a fifth
and a sixth of the reserve oil he
bragged about releasing to boost supply
made its way offshore to europe and asia
in june
biden authorized the release of a
million barrels a day from april onwards
but his action has done little to combat
soaring gas prices with the national
average sitting at 474 as of tuesday
still far above the 228 a gallon average
uh from just before he took office from
220 to 474.
five million barrels abroad to europe
and asia and then and that and then one
like how explain to me
we were
we're in a shortage explain to me how
you think sending all that
overseas is going to help us
what the what does that even mean
like we're sending we don't have it you
guys are paying for it we're sending it
how is that going to make the price go
down like it's like it would seem what
it would seem to me that every decision
that has been made by the biden
administration associated with this
ukraine invasion as we describe it has
been nothing short of disastrous for the
american people while it has been good
for raytheon to a certain extent
obviously because they want more weapons
and the democrats could not push for
more wars and more weapons because they
take money from the raytheons and the
lockheed martins of the world and i can
share with you the numbers and they're
kind of disgusting how much the profits
have gone up since the uh ukrainian
situation started but also from an
energy standpoint the american people
are getting hosed because of biden's
policies having to do with ukraine and
everything and that and by the way
that's not to say that i'm agreeing with
freaking putin and what he's done in
ukraine obviously but the way we've
handled it those who are being hurt by
it are the american people and certainly
not uh you know some some of guidance
donors for example so the whole thing
just really smells the whole thing
stinks to high heaven so uh i don't
think we can get away from that and i
think it's gonna be some biden's gonna
be dealing with for quite some time his
foreign policy by the way sucks so so
here's a question for you adam here's a
question for
any one of you guys here but
specifically adam curious here's what
you have to say
how many of the people that voted for
trump and were true believers of trump
flipped on him what percentage
since the january 6th hearings during
his first three years minus kovit
what percentage of the people that voted
for trump flipped on him in the first
three are saying this is a terrible vote
i should have never voted oh very few
okay so how many people who voted for
obama
three months three years later said you
know what a terrible vote i should never
voted for obama very few i agree of
course how many people flipped on bush
three years later saying horrible what i
should have never voted for bush uh a
lot because of the iraq war
okay fair how many people said that with
uh clinton three years later
uh not a lot pre-monika none
pre-monitored again everything i'm
saying primarily
right
how many people within the first three
years who voted for biden are saying
what the hell did i just do a very good
question what do you think that
percentage is because it's not like it's
republicans are being sold alive stop
throwing the gun under the bus give the
guy a second chance no no his own people
who voted for him are throwing him under
the bus at this point and that
percentage is a big percentage of people
who voted for this guy i think i i think
they they're realizing now it was like
you know when you when you buy something
just you just like you just want to
purchase it
impose but it was an impulse vote
because you know kovit and the media and
with that that that whirlwind was it was
trump and trump oh he said they came
from china racist all that that
whirlwind they were like all right
listen anything will do they could have
literally had a weakened at bernie's
dead body which biden kind of is they
would have voted for anybody and now now
that they're seeing it now that their
wallets are hurting they're like oh [ __ ]
we were i mean
kind of got duped into it you're stuck
with it well though vince to a certain
extent presidencies are circumstantial
you are a uh byproduct of the
circumstances that you inherit to be
fair with trump or to be fair with obama
or to be fair with anybody even this
does that mr mr sleepy yeah um
there are some things you could cogently
say that he has had laid upon him which
were very difficult to manage that said
that's your [ __ ] job i agree okay fdr
didn't say all these freaking nazis this
is not fair no nazis are there you gotta
take them on yeah you know uh when obama
had to deal with the meltdown you know
give him credit he dealt with it i don't
necessarily like the way he dealt with
it but he dealt with it and he helped so
you got to deal with what you're dealt
man those are the cards here you got you
got an h no you got no aces oh sorry and
uh you know people will say that it's a
circumstantial situation for biden but
on top of the fact that he's had tough
circumstances i will give him that this
inflation situation was not made by him
um he's not dealing with it properly nor
is he capable of dealing with it
properly because he's not a strong
leader that's my point
great uh i i think
i think it's going to be very
interesting how much worse it can get
under him like he's not even wanted to
come out like this one lady democratic
strategist just said to follow i just
want to read this one quote and go to
the last story which is the highland
park it's infuriating said one top
democratic strategist venting
frustrations about biden and his team
our house is on fire and it seems like
they're doing nothing to put out the
fire they're just watching it with the
rest of us so
meaning here's the policies you said you
were gonna go through you have the house
you have every it's all you and you
can't get [ __ ] done we thought you're
gonna get everything done now what do we
do it's catastrophic midterms i just
can't wait for midterms to see what
happens there last story highland park
okay bali tragic event on what happened
in highland park
um
the fourth of july shootings uh suspect
suspect charged with seven counts of
first degree murder on tuesday the lake
county state attorney eric reinhardt
announced that a suspect robert creamo
iii has been charged with seven counts
of first-degree murder in connection to
the mass shooting at highland park
fourth of july parade we anticipate
dozens of more charges centering around
each of the victims psychological
victims physical victims attempted
murder charges aggravated discharge
discharge charges aggravated battery
charges there will be dozens more
charges against mr cremo but these seven
counts of first degree murder will lead
to a mandatory life sentence should he
be convicted without the possibility of
parole uh and then you have a couple
other stories i'll read one of them here
to you uh uh highland park tells uh um
boom
police flagged highland park shooter
clear and present danger in 2019 he
later cleared four background checks
robert bobby cremo the third 21 years
old the suspect in a mass shooting that
killed seven people and wounded dozens
of others on fourth of july parade was
still able to clear state required
background checks to purchase firearms
on at least four separate occasions
between 2020 and 2021 the illinois state
police reported in september 2019 isp
received a clear and present danger
report on the subject from the highland
park police department the report was
related to threats the subject made
against his family
and uh not willing to move forward on a
complaint next thing you know obviously
this is documented and even take place
you have any thoughts on this adam
i mean
at this point we're just going to go run
around in circles and talk about what
needs to get done here and you know
background checks
health mental health the gun it's it's
just we're just talking in circles here
you talked about you shot a video and
you're like oh we need a after you've
all day uh a how-to video what can we do
about gun control and you talked about
well i think we need to redo the video
because of this shooting and then i
not even sarcastically i said well don't
wait too long to do that because there's
going to be another shooting
and that's the
look we're going to talk in circles here
the the kid somehow his father co-signed
to get the gun and he passed these uh
background checks somehow this kid you
showed a video today that he reenacted
what he would do and nobody did nothing
so
i think you know extreme times drastic
times called for drastic measures i'm
going to give an angle that nobody i
don't hear talking about
the family of this person or the family
of any shooter what happens to them
nothing what happens like i understand
that the the father didn't pull the
trigger or the grandma or the uncle paul
but
these people have a complete lack of
regard for human life
but i assume at some in some level in
their life this person cares about his
grandma or cares about his dad or his
family or his sister
and i'm not saying that those people
need to go to jail over this but that
family
something needs to happen to have
accountability whereas as you're about
to this [ __ ] kid dresses up as a
woman covers up his tattoos and he's
going on a roof and he's about to shoot
a bunch of people
and he knows that he's going to say all
right once i do this i'm going to jail
the rest of my life or i'm going to die
and that's it he's only thinking about
himself but in the back of your mind if
you're an active shooter and you're
thinking whoa hold on
this is really my entire family is gonna
uh
face the ramifications of this or my
grandma's gonna go to jail i'm going way
completely out of people and i like i
like maybe that will be like well and
trigger no pun intended something an
embassy you know what
i love my family to i hate myself i hate
people the girl that didn't want to kiss
me in school the video game my butt like
something extreme needs to be done here
because if it's still red flag laws
background checks mental health you know
accessibility guns it's the same [ __ ]
talking points we need to do something
different and you know what tripped me
out about this story when i heard this
and how it's crazy how this happened in
chicago right how this gets only this
type of mass shooting got it's you know
people are still talking about was all
big do you know how many mass shootings
are and you talked about this adam a
couple podcasts ago it's like three or
more people right uh chicago from
september of may uh 2018 till today
811 people killed or injured in mass
release this this one's the only one
that gets this past weekend i think
there was like 80 or
some people shot and like i think
another nine or ten on top of this it's
just crazy how that gets story it's
those people that were at the parade
that mattered but all the people that
are getting killed all the minorities
inside chicago that may or whoever is
the mayor of chicago i get it horrible
job what do you do like like we keep
talking about changing everything you
guys got to do how do you how do you
still have a job as a mayor of chicago i
know it's a f
whoever comes in it's horrible none of
them are really doing anything here's a
crazy thing about this this uh this guy
his father
ran against the current highland parks
mayor as a mayor mayoral race i don't
know if you got what i just said the
democratic killers the the guy that did
that his dad ran against the current
mayor of the city where he was shooting
wow
that's that's a little creepy right
there
yeah when you hear the story i think the
takeaway is when your son shows up at
home and he has a tattoo on his forehead
and on his cheek you've got a problem
and don't let him get a gun
or would they wear those tight tight um
army shoes that yeah and you know people
my dad would have kicked my ass
if i would have shown up i mean my dad
used to not let me come into the house
without having to look at him in the eye
yes the [ __ ] about you get into your
house late at night when your parents
are yeah of course you know what my dad
would do he went to sleep in my bed to
make sure i had to wake him up but and
then i had to face him to me sure i
wasn't stoned or drunk or had something
else going there's a lot of it's called
accountability i agree i agree and
there's a lot of gen z younger kids
where like it's cool to get tattoos on
your faces so i'm not saying just
because you get a tattoo on your face
you're going to become a killer but this
like this guy was a clear and present
danger that's that's the police marked
him as that in 2019 and then his father
sponsored his so here's my point the
father didn't do anything wrong
they lived in the same house the uncle
the father and the and when he was
interviewed
where the father the uncle the grandma
they all need to go to [ __ ] jail
okay okay
it sounds bombastic and sarcastic
no
this
one guy took down seven lives so what
we're gonna just punish the kid and he
goes to jail i like what adam something
drastic needs to get done so this time
going off your dressing which i kind of
i kind of like i thought of it like as
you know we let terrorists know because
they're you know everybody loves their
family if you are a shooter and you kill
let's say seven people we're just giving
you a heads up so yes everybody be on
alert we're gonna kill seven people and
you're in your family we're gonna off
them they're gonna be [ __ ] not now
you just show to everybody you're from
iran
yeah but that's extremely cool
what type of extreme measures that they
do because here's my thing nothing
there's no solution no nobody's even
trying how about this a heads up school
shooters if you shoot somebody period in
the school we're going to go after your
[ __ ] family and make them suffer okay
can we try that no because that wouldn't
be legal and i get that that's not what
the american shooting is i get that
that's not the american way i get that
you have a bad kid i get that that's not
the american way but you know it's not
the america rick i hear you
went to a completely different world
that's not what i'm doing from iran
goddammit that's not what our justin
system is you're getting misbehave
you're playing you know what else is not
the american way showing up to salute
your country on july 4th and getting
shot the [ __ ] dead yeah because you
wanted to celebrate your country so like
this person right here needs to be held
as a domestic terrorist on july 4th he's
killing people you know what that was at
a parade if you're the parent of a kid
that's crazy kind and has tattoos and is
clear and present danger guess what that
parent's gonna be way more involved hell
yeah free shooting i agree with adam hey
by the way by the way hey are you
wearing military boots to school [ __ ]
stay in the house i'm not even in your
crazy back i get that that's not what
our justice system is built on yeah but
what says what are we gonna do here says
the two the only two guys room with no
kids thank you
okay hang on a minute let's not forget
these shooters shot his grandmother in
the face
yeah like before he went out and killed
a bunch of people so i'm not sure how
much your theory would
maybe it will slow it down a little bit
again she should have seen it coming to
be fair and i listen my daughter's only
19 months i'm kidding it would be more
interesting to hear pat's take on this
but i would feel as a parent the hardest
thing i could do is lose faith in my
daughter like the hardest thing i could
do is lose faith in my child and say
listen this is a bad kid this is a bad
egg i need to do something about it and
not to mention what kind of a [ __ ]
slippery slope are you going down when
you're now prosecuting family members i
mean how far and how broad can that be
okay i mean i think it's what solutions
do you have though
where's the accountability
where's the accountability in the house
morally your solution is spot on we're
not we're not disagreeing with you more
the law the law isn't it what you're
essentially saying is parents should
start being accountable and responsible
children by making sure that they're
involved and engaged in their children's
lives and that's a great point that
you're making but when you take it to
the point that we need to start
prosecuting them for the actions of
their children that gets a little iffy
unless of course they bought him a gun
or stuck a gun
accountability i'm not saying it needs
to be jail time they need to be fined
and they need to like lose something
needs to happen to these families didn't
one of those parents go to jail those
two the two parents of i don't know
which school shooting back yeah two of
them got arrested and they went to jail
because they gave him this gun but at
what point does this stop being
a government issue where we just force
laws and actually become a cultural
change i mean when are we gonna realize
that this is an issue with the culture
in the country right now well how do you
change the culture
start disciplining your kids
you can't even you can't guys
stop playing video games so much stop
watching the movie
i think parents i think parents there
listen i think it was two generations of
my i'm not saying hit your kids
disciplining your kids became taboo can
i ask you guys a question why did jordan
peterson all of a sudden become
mainstream
why did jordan peterson all of a sudden
blow up the way he did what did he start
talking about
say that again he's pushing a message
that people they're they're longing for
it they're hurting for it they want to
hear it so he gave a message about what
it is to be a man okay so he's helping
boys become men he's talking about
personal responsibility bingo the 12
rules of life
clean your bed you know make your do
this all these basic to think about
nothing he said
is like e equals m c square oh my god
everything he said is just basic stuff
that you know
many people a generation ago were being
taught that it skipped a generation that
they're not teaching
i'm going to keep saying this over and
over again this goes back to values and
principles this goes back to values and
principles
choose a religion okay
that has got the right values and
principles and start telling schools to
pray i don't care what it is whether
it's prayer values and principles 10
commandments i don't care which one of
these it is
make it a requirement to start teaching
basic values and principles now
of course
adam's got a very good point because the
responsibilities on the parent
so where this goes even more to
uh you know a single family household
where you know there's a single parent
household kids are being raised by that
but this this has to be the main if
there's any books that you can write
right now that i believe will do very
well that people want to read if there's
any channels you can create any content
you can create anything you can write
about anything you can build
your mo of your youtube channel your
blog your website your whatever you're
doing this has this will do very very
well right now the next five 10 15 20
years and i don't think this is going to
go away anytime soon
because most of the churches that are
you go to nowadays a lot of them are out
of touch this being ran by a 72 year old
pastor and he's given messages that just
he has a hard time connecting with the
audience i went to a couple of them i
won the biggest churches in dallas i
went to i sat there on easter and i said
dude you just don't connect with me i
have a hard time connecting with you
where's dudley rutherford who connected
with everybody in la right i think
there's a big opportunity in churches
and i think there's a big opportunity
for people who are teaching the right
morals the right values and the right
principles until we start doing that and
by the way
my messaging of what i'm saying guess
how long the ship's going to take with
my strategy how long do you think a long
long time 20 decades decades 20 years by
the decades by the way uh
not to bring it back to what uh i'm
doing but um i'm gonna bring it back to
what i'm doing
you will find within the latino
community in the united states and
latinos in general the adherence to
parental obedience is bigger and better
than it is in most other cohorts
for some reason
when i fear my dad's gonna kick my ass
for something i even thought before i
did it i tended not to do it and we are
raised that way
it's a moralistic kind of teaching but
somehow maybe it comes from catholicism
i don't know
uh maybe it comes from our own sense of
christianity maybe it does maybe it
doesn't i'm not saying everybody has to
be like uh think like me because i
happen to be a christian but something
in the latino dna makes people
less apt to want to be lazy and more apt
to be want to work and have accept
personal responsibility and and when i'm
doing uh rick sanchez news my podcast
that's something i constantly try to
make sure that i talk about because it's
a it's about fitting the people to the
argument no matter what the story is on
that day which which makes me think as
we're discussing this you're probably
going to be less apt to see that kind of
behavior in our community i think which
is a good thing but having cuban friends
uh i think it comes down to the
chancleta
i don't know what your parents used to
hit me with my dad was a belt but in the
cuban household in miami they'll take a
smile my mother used to spend the front
porch in our house in hialeah and saying
in other words i'm not going to hit you
i'm not going to hit you coming in i
know i'd been bad and then she'd wait
there by the porch and as soon as i
tried to stick to the house wow yeah she
would hit me and i was like oh my god i
knew this was going to happen and she
gets me everywhere accountability my mom
who cooks a lot she should have a wooden
spoon like an old school wooden spoon
and we'd do something insane and she
would hit us and the and it broke which
took her to a whole nother level because
it was my she stabbed you that bro yeah
but i think like especially the latino
community and this i don't think it's
it's a minority thing but like middle
easterns and the disciplining of your
kids and we were scared the thought like
six words if your mother said put you in
your place six words wait until your
father gets home that i'm like no i'm
like i'll clean i'll kiss your feet yeah
cause if he knew it was over i think
that that's gone away in this in the in
this culture now is you can't even you
can't even tell them anything because
they'll get snitched like you can't told
me this you told me that touched me how
much of this has to do with technology
and the fact that we don't spend enough
time it's big talking and and sharing
these ideas just throw an ipad at them
take this
people uh you know millions of people
are probably going to be listening to
this conversation because they don't
have somebody to have a conversation
with so they have to rely on patrick and
his friends to have a conversation and
to a certain extent that's great because
at least we're having a coget decent
conversation
but i would almost encourage those
people once in a while to go have a
conversation with your son or your uncle
or your daughter or whoever because i
don't think that's happening and that's
what i see out of that story out of
highland park illinois that that's not
happening when you live with a boy
because this kid was a boy
and he lives in your house and you've
been there 10 years living in that house
with them and a reporter comes and asks
him tell me about him and you say i
don't know anything about him all right
you got a problem yeah and if that's
indicative of america we got a problem
yep i totally agree
you know uh final thoughts here how much
of a role does the president play on how
fathers lead their kids how much
credence you put on that or is it more
tv dads like you know how there was a tv
that will smith's dad whatever his name
was you know uh uncle fell
bill cosby was a you know he was a tv
dad a lot of guys have played a tv that
how much of a role you think the
president the leader of a nation plays
on how to help raise your kids quite a
lot quite a lot what do you think would
you what do you think i'm actually
curious i don't know the survey but what
do you think you're saying quite a lot
what do you think i mean if he accepts
it what's gravity what i'm gravitating
to is when uh on the debate stage when
they asked hillary and trump to say one
nice thing about the opponent and
hillary said yes yeah you know one thing
else good nice thing i'll say about
donald trump is at least you've raised
some good kids that's great i mean that
was great so so if what you guys are
saying is true which a tough father
produces great kids
then how would you rate biden's style of
raising kids because so i don't know not
gold because the product on how the
product is doing whether it's hunter or
all that other stuff and you look at a
trump or you look at obama's kids or you
look at like i don't see michelle being
a passive passive me neither yeah i see
michelle being tough i don't see obama
being tough but i see michelle being
tough i see trump have an expectation
oh i agree i think no no i i agree so to
me
i don't know and by the way let me tell
you i don't think this is an 18-month
thing since biden's taking pause
i think this has been a conversation
we've gotten away from for a couple
decades you don't get to point like this
overnight you get to a point like this
it's a gradual process of getting there
but to work it out of this place uh it's
not gonna be a two-year deal a four-year
deal i think you used your great
expression earlier today on another
matter this man is an accidental
president so to use him as an example of
what's happening from the president
but by the way not all
kids are created equal i mean for
instance he did lose his son beau biden
who was a full-on military hero purple
heart
lost his life in battle correct and so
that's like someone like him and the
other one is a lot different from hunter
who's a drug who's a full-on crackhead
yeah who's a lot different from ashley
biden who literally i partied with at
tulane like back in the late 90s that's
a fair point was a party girl like
so not all kids are the same just like
you know you have your four kids they're
not all exactly the same can you tell me
anything about that party after the show
yeah sure everyone want to know about
that
party girl no wonder he defends the
biting family as much as he says that
would make sense ashley's got him by
by the
okay all right sounds good well gang
this was a blast rick appreciate you for
coming out you got a blast with you
was great i feel like i was with my
brother
follow the man's podcast rick sanchez
news on apple podcast tyler put the link
below so people can find it easily uh uh
we just got a word that boris johnson
resigned he gave the speech which is
kind of interesting the guy resigned we
haven't had a chance to get into it
maybe we will next week
early this morning yeah bro earlier this
morning but anyways gank have a great
weekend am i in town next week or yeah
i'm at town next week we are back next
tuesday with john paul mack isaac the
owner of the laptop store in delaware
that found the hunter laptop
oh my god so that so that's adam's going
to be in tulane though he's not going to
be here so he's skipping that one
anyways have a great weekend we'll see
you guys on tuesday
you